sometimes on the David Pakman show we
talked about ignorant on major
life-altering issues like ignorance on
climate change
ignorance on basic economics or on net
neutrality and sometimes we talk about
ignorant on the littler things and this
is sort of an in-between Donald Trump
seems to think that DNA tests like the
ones you get from ancestry.com or
23andme cost two dollars and will tell
you where you were born and when I first
heard about this my initial reaction was
that this can't possibly be true and
then I remembered well Trump did confuse
health insurance and life insurance he
wasn't sure why it wasn't a good idea to
nuke Europe he had this wacky rally in
Montana totally lost his mind at it and
he seemed to say that when you do a DNA
test which he thinks you buy for two
bucks off of I guess a TV infomercial I
don't know I don't know what channels
he's watching it will tell you the
country you were born and this is funny
for a number of reasons but the number
one reason is do that many people not
know where they were born
check out this cringe-worthy video of
Donald Trump let's say I'm debating
Pocahontas right I promise you I'll do
this I will take you know those little
kits they sell on television for two
dollars learn your heritage guy says I
was born in Scotland it turns out he was
born in Puerto Rico and that's okay you
know
okay says I was born in Germany well he
wasn't born in Germany he was born
someplace else I'm gonna get one of
those little kids how great is this most
people ask their mom or dad where they
were born not everyone right like there
are unique situations where someone
might not know where they were born
different situations we can imagine most
people know not only does a DNA does not
tell you where you were born
most people know where they were born
yeah I think he's confusing Elizabeth
Warren with Barack Obama North to find
out where Obama was born which he of
course says is Kenya yes unfortunately
the DNA test won't tell you that and I
mean okay on the $2 thing Trump
supposedly a billionaire so maybe two
dollars and two hundred dollars is
really no difference the same thing to
him but DNA tests tell you where you
were born and
your question is how does this guy get
away with this stuff I figured it out
he's slightly smarter than his
supporters so when he makes these
statements they just don't register as
that stupid because he's just he only
has to be the tiniest bit more informed
than his supporters and the context in
case you couldn't tell he mentioned the
word Pocahontas the context is his
continuing obsession with Senator
Elizabeth Warren's partial Native
American heritage the issue won't die
with Trump it's like Hillary's emails or
Hillary's uranium one conspiracy or
Hillary's three to five million illegal
votes the trend is it has to a lot to do
with Hillary
it just won't die and he seems fixated
on this thing and people might have
forgotten Pat but I actually did an
ancestry.com DNA test and a 23andme
dot-com DNA test and we've had blamed
Bettinger who's up DNA expert on the
program if you missed that episode he
revealed to the audience in incredibly
dramatic fashion that he has never seen
someone with a higher percentage of
Ashkenazi Jewish DNA than my DNA which
was a finding that was both interesting
to normal people and triggering for the
anti-semitic hatreds yeah I took that
ancestry DNA test too and it said that I
was less than 1% Ashkenazi Jewish which
I thought was pretty interesting yeah
although he told us less than 1% is
often just statistical noise and it
basically is like zero so I'm not Indian
nor will America neither it no I don't
think so I think you got what did yours
come out it was like British and
Lebanese British Irish Lebanese Italian
Greek polish Russian a little of
everything was there anything that was
surprising about what was it I didn't
know it was Italian and Greek you didn't
know now I got to eat a bunch of pasta
and embrace my heritage right yes no you
should do the most stereotypical things
that would be colloquially associated
without with all of those Heritage's
anyway I think that I got screwed with
my test because it didn't tell me where
I was born that's something I would I
would have liked to know because I only
think I know the answer to that today's
program is made possible in part by
futur futur is a social forecasting game
where you compete with other players to
predict the future and it's built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
a scientifically proven way of using the
wisdom of the crowd to create more
accurate predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between you can check
out my predictions and follow me to get
updates on my profile which is linked to
in the description if you're watching
this on YouTube the tour is a great tool
to find out more about the world improve
your forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecasts it's free and it's available
on both Android and iOS and right now on
foote or you can win cash prizes for
correct predictions about the World Cup
check it out at fut you you are calm